Hi, everyone.
I am Dr. Adina
Leder, and today
I am discussing
from myelopathy
to myopathy.
The session objectives
of this lecture
today is to explain
how to localize
based on clinical
presentation,
describe how to
exclude treatable
causes of potentially
fatal disorders,
correlate the
differential diagnosis
of disease at each
level of the motor
unit, and we're going
to apply treatment
options if there
are any available.
Then we also
will be able to
identify a
neurological emergency.
So overview includes,
we're going to start
in the spinal cord
and look at spinal
cord disorders. These
are called myelopathies.
We'll go through
the anterior horn
cell disorders, motor
neuron disorders,
ventral root
disorders, also
known as radiculopathies,
dorsal root
ganglion disorders,
plexopathies,
peripheral neuropathies,
demyelinating disorders,
and axonal changes,
neuromuscular
junction disorders,
and then down into
the myopathies.
so this is a picture
of the motor unit and
the arrow here is pointing
to the spinal cord
which is what we're
going to be starting
with so the first case
is a 15 year old boy
who presents with anxiety
migraines and adhd
who has rapidly
progressive lower extremity
weakness a month prior
to the weakness he
developed fever and
flu-like symptoms with
myalgia in both legs the
leg weakness persists
despite resolution
of flu-like symptoms.
On an MRI, there is
linear hyperintensity
in the gray matter
in the thoracic
region, and you
can see where the
arrow is pointing
that there is some
light spots within
the spinal cord. The
CSF showed predominant
lymphocytes.
this is what's
called acute flaccid
myelitis and basically
it is flaccid
limb weakness after
viral infection the
reflexes are reduced
and it is often
associated with
different pathogens
specifically
enteroviruses D68
and D71. It could
also be seen
with poliovirus
and flaviviruses.
This often occurs
most commonly after
a respiratory or a
GI virus. It's more
common in children,
and an outbreak
like this may occur
every other year.
so when you're
confronting a spinal cord
lesion the way that
i like to remember
all the different parts
of the differential
is by using the
mnemonic vitamins
so the first is
v for vascular i
infectious or post
-infectious traumatic
autoimmune toxic
metabolic inflammatory
neoplastic,
or structural.
And to the right,
the image shows if
there was a lesion
at each of these
levels, what type of
weakness you would
see and at what level
this would occur.
So these are some of
the things that could
be seen within the
differential. So for
a vascular event in
the spinal cord, you
would consider
something like a spinal
cord infarct or a
vascular malformation.
In terms of an
infection to the
spinal cord, you
would consider virus,
bacteria, ******,
or post-viral.
In terms of
traumatic, there could
be decompression
illness or trauma
for autoimmune,
lupus, Sjogren's,
demyelinating
diseases such as MS,
neuromyelitis
optica, and MOG is a
newer identified
demyelinating condition
that's more often
seen in children.
In terms of metabolic
issues, you could
see B12 deficiency,
drug exposures, nitrous
oxide toxicity, inflammatory
neurosarcoidosis
has to be considered
in terms of
neoplastic spinal cord
tumors, whether they're
primary or metastatic,
and structural,
a syrinx or a fluid
-filled cavity within
the spinal cord could
also be considered.
In terms of the symptoms
of a myelopathy,
or what's a spinal
cord lesion, it
depends on the tracks
and the disease
process. So patients
will often present
with gait instability
or imbalance,
stiffness or clumsiness,
weakness in the
arms and or legs,
depending on the level of
the spinal cord lesion.
There can be often
urinary urgency and
or bowel incontinence.
There's also something
called the sensory
level. And at that
level, it could appear
to be the patient
complains of either an
irritating band
sensation at the superior
margin. There could be
numbness or tingling
below the level. Sometimes
they describe what
feels like a belt
that's squeezing them.
There can also be
episodic muscle spasms
that will cause
unintentional extension
of legs or cramping
in the calves.
And some of the
signs of a myelopathy
could be flaccid
paralysis,
which is the signs of
a corticospinal tract
disruption, and it
can evolve to weakness
with increased tone
and brisk reflexes.
A Babinski sign
can be seen, which
is an extensor
plantar response.
When you ******
the lateral part of
the sole of the
foot, the toe is up.
And on the side,
there are some videos
that you can
look at at your
convenience. There's
also a Hoffman
sign, which is an
upper extremity
equivalent of a lower
extremity reflex.
So similar to Babinski
sign, but it's
in the upper
extremity, and that
can reflect a
cervical cord lesion.
So the upper motor
neurons originate in
the primary motor
cortex of the brain. The
axons comprise the
corticobulbar tract and
the corticospinal
tract. The corticobulbar
tract goes to the
brainstem. The corticospinal
tract connects to
the spinal cord.
The lower motor neurons
are also known as
alpha motor neurons or
anterior horn cells,
and they are located
in the motor nuclei
in the brainstem or the
anterior gray matter
of the spinal cord.
The axons connect to
muscles of the bulbar
region or the limbs.
And so you can see
the arrow pointing to
the anterior horn of
the spinal cord. And
that is what we're
going to discuss next.
So this is case two.
The year is 1999,
and a 73-year-old man
from Queens was
presented to the hospital
with fever, headache,
rash, and body aches.
His symptoms progressed
to flaccid paralysis.
There were absent
reflexes. He had
difficulty speaking,
and he was unable to
swallow, which is
dysarthria and dysphagia.
He then had significant
difficulty with
breathing, developed
respiratory
failure, and needed
to be ventilated. He
was brought to Long
Island Jewish Hospital
and was in the
intensive care unit.
He was found to
have West Nile
virus, and this is
one of the first
cases that was
found in 1999. 9.
Neuroinvasive
disease is uncommon
and occurs in less
than 1% of people,
but of 5-10% of
neuroinvasive cases
can be associated
with myelitis.
Specifically, it
appears like a
polio-like illness
with acute flaccid
paralysis,
decreased reflexes,
and bowel and
bladder dysfunction.
This is a flavivirus.
It often can start
with fever, rash,
myalgia, but more commonly
they could see meningitis
or encephalitis.
The anterior horn
syndrome refers to
lower motor neuron
degeneration and
weakness is seen.
There is preservation
of all sensory
modalities. Some of
the examples of
anterior horn syndromes
include spinal
muscular atrophy,
spinal and
bulbar muscular
atrophy, such as
Kennedy disease,
West Nile myelitis,
and polio myelitis.
So spinal muscular
atrophy is a group of
inherited disorders where
there is degeneration
of anterior horn
cells. The most
common type is caused
by a variation in what's
called SMN, or Survival
Motor Neuron 1.
We are now up to nine
recognized types,
which have been
identified, and all
involve a varying
degree of weakness.
The clinical
presentation varies from
early death and
infancy, which is type 0
and 1A, up to type
4, which the patient
can walk independently
as an adult.
Poliomyelitis is a
highly infectious
enterovirus. 1% of
infected patients will
develop acute
paralytic syndrome due
to infection of the
anterior horn cells.
There are painful
muscle spasms that
occur before flaccid
weakness, and it
could be either
spinal and or bulbar.
Vaccination remains
the main means of
polio prevention.
And therefore,
there's the risk that
this can occur if
patients are not
getting vaccinated.
The iron lung
was seen in the
1940s and 50s,
and a vaccine
was not developed
until 1955.
However, patients who
were extremely sick
were placed in this
iron lung, and the
picture is seen there
to keep them alive.
Case 3 is a 67-year
-old man who presented
with an eight-month
history of slurred
speech. Over that same
time period, he had
weakness of the left
hand without numbness.
Cramping was noted in
his hands and legs,
and he admitted to
crying spontaneously.
this is ALS or
amyotrophic lateral
sclerosis the motor
symptoms include weakness
of limbs with
atrophy or wasting of
the muscles there
are bulbar symptoms
that could include
speaking difficulty with
speaking chewing
and swallowing and
reflexes are brisk
there's pseudobulbar
affect so laughing or
crying, which isn't
necessarily under
voluntary control.
Cognitive features
include a small proportion
that also have
frontotemporal dementia.
And so ALS is a
combination of upper
and lower motor
neuron symptoms.
Some examples of the
lower motor neuron
symptoms include
weakness, fasciculations,
which is like a
rippling of the muscles
without actual
contraction, and there's
atrophy or wasting of
the muscles. The upper
motor neuron findings
include spasticity,
hyperreflexia, and
pathologic reflexes such
as a Babinski. A
retained reflex in a limb
that is weak is considered
abnormal, and that
could be a clinical
clue. So if a patient
has a weak leg and yet
they still have a brisk
reflex, then it has
to be considered that
there's something that
needs to be further
investigated. In terms
of the pelvic floor,
urinary and ******
sphincters are unaffected.
And so this slide
has been added
to as there
are more famous
people that have
developed ALS.
You can see Lou Gehrig
all the way on the left,
Stephen Hawkins is to
the right of Lou Gehrig.
Eric Dean is to the
right of Stephen Hawkins,
and then Steve
Gleason is a famous
football player who was
diagnosed with ALS as
well. And many of
these people have gone
public to raise awareness
of this condition.
Next area is what's
called the dorsal root
ganglion, and the
blue arrow is showing
exactly where
this area is.
So case four is a 78
-year-old man with other
comorbidities who
presents with several
days of severe pain on
the right side of his
thorax. On examination,
there is a vesicular
rash present along
the T6 distribution.
And here you can
see some different
images of ******
zoster, which is
localized to the
dorsal root ganglion.
So varicella zoster
virus, these are
****** viruses, HSV1,
2, and VZV. They
reside in the dorsal
root and trigeminal
ganglia. VZV causes
two conditions,
the primary
infection, varicella,
which is
chickenpox, and then
the reactivation
infection, which
is ******, zoster,
or shingles.
Zoster is a common
complication of a
prior varicella
infection, and vesicular
lesions occur
along a dermatome,
which you saw in
the previous slide.
The possible
etiologies of a DRG
or a dorsal root
ganglion lesion.
It's also known as a
sensory neuronopathy.
Include infectious
causes such as HIV,
HTLV, EBV, Zika, and VZV.
These are all infections.
Perineoplastic,
small cell
lung cancer,
breast, ovarian,
autoimmune. includes
Sjogren's, lupus,
or rheumatoid
arthritis, and drugs
include cisplatin, which
is a chemotherapeutic
agent, and from
a hereditary
standpoint, Fabrese,
although less common,
can also cause a
sensory neuronopathy.
And so features of a
dorsal root ganglion
lesion include a
non-length dependent
asymmetric sensory
deficit with preserved
motor strength.
The proximal areas
can be affected prior
to distal areas,
which include upper
extremities, face,
and trunk. It's common
to have pain. There
could be profound
sensory loss with
gait and limitaxia
and absent reflexes.
And moving down to
the ventral root,
you can see where
the arrow is.
So case 5 is a 45
-year-old man who
presents to the
emergency room with
severe pain in the
left lumbar region.
Onset was one week
ago when he sneezed.
He experienced
radiation of pain
down the left leg.
There has been
progressive worsening
over the past week.
On examination, a
foot drop was present.
There was about
three out of five
dorsiflexion
weakness on the left
leg. The ankle reflex
is diminished on
the left and there
was sensory loss on
the lateral aspect
of the left leg.
In terms of the
differential,
it is most common
to have a herniated
intervertebral disc
and spondylosis.
There could be a
synovial cyst, an
infection such as a
myelitis or discitis,
vertebral fracture,
a bony malignant lesion,
or an epidural hematoma.
And the symptoms
of radiculopathy
can include
radiating pain,
reduced reflex along
a spinal route. There
could be sensory loss
and muscle weakness
that's applied by the
corresponding nerves.
And here is an image.
You can see on top is
the normal disc and
below then there's the
bulging disc and at the
bottom is the herniated
disc where the
material is thrust out.
Next we're going
into the plexus
and here's an image
of the plexus.
So case 6 is a 25-year
-old man who presents
with severe attacks
of pain in the left
upper arm followed by
patchy muscle weakness.
On examination, there's
weakness, patchy
sensory loss, and
atrophy in the upper arm.
This is actually
neuralgic amyotrophy, and
it can also be known
as Parsonage-Turner
syndrome, which is a
type of plexopathy. It
typically presents
with acute onset of
shoulder pain that's
localized to one side,
the pain resolves, but
then a sensory loss
and weakness occurs
in the affective limb.
The risk factors
include recent viral
illness or surgery, and
this is inflammatory
in nature. And over
time, it can improve.
And just a quick
reminder of what
the brachial
plexus looks like.
The possible causes
of a plexopathy could
be trauma, including
a traumatic birth
injury or motor vehicle
accident. There could
be neoplasm, primary
or metastatic disease,
radiation for an
underlying cancer
which can occur, the
symptoms may occur months
to years later.
It could be due to
compression or entrapment.
There can be infection
to the area including
****** zoster.
Inflammatory immune
or autoimmune
can cause this
or there could be
hereditary or
idiopathic causes.
Now we're going down
to the peripheral
nerve, and case seven
is a 56-year-old
man with poorly
controlled diabetes,
hypertension, and
elevated cholesterol.
He states that his
feet feel numb, and he
was dropping things
lately. On exam,
there is reduced
sensation in a stocking
glove distribution
in hands and feet.
And this is the typical
distal symmetric
polyneuropathy in
a stocking glove
pattern. In the darker
areas are where it is
most affected, and
there's more numbness
in the darker areas,
and as you go up,
he could feel a
little bit more.
so distal symmetric
polyneuropathy is
most commonly caused by
diabetes or prediabetes
it can be due to
infectious neuropathies
chemotherapy can
cause this chronic
alcohol use and other
toxins there could
be b12 deficiency
hereditary causes
include hereditary motor
sensory neuropathy,
and then entrapments
such as carpal
tunnel syndrome or
other mononeuropathies.
So leprosy is a common
cause of chronic,
severe, and mutilating
infectious neuropathy
that occurs in tropical
and subtropical
parts of the world. This
condition is endemic
in Africa, Eastern
Pacific, and Western
Mediterranean. It's
due to mycobacteria,
leprae, or
lepromatosis, and
interestingly some
armadillos are
naturally affected
with leprosy.
Molokai in Hawaii is
a former ***** colony.
We are now at
a point where
diabetes has caused
more peripheral
neuropathy than leprosy.
So working our way down
to the myelin sheath.
Case 8 is a 25-year
-old woman who presents
with back pain and
numbness in her feet.
Over the past day,
numbness has been
spreading up to
her knees. She had
a gastroenteritis
a few weeks ago.
On examination, reflexes
are absent, and on
the lumbar puncture,
she was found to have
albuminocytologic
dissociation,
which means that
there is an elevated
protein but a
normal cell count.
and this is consistent
with what's called
Guillain-Barré
syndrome and this
encompasses a group
of related disorders.
AIDP which is
acute inflammatory
demyelinating polyradicular
neuropathy is the
most common form.
This can occur post
-infectious and can be
paralytic. The common
infections include
CMV, mycoplasma,
EBV,
influenza, and flu.
In terms of bacteria,
Campylobacter is the
most frequently caused
after a bad GI bout,
and it can be also found
after Zika virus and
COVID-19 infections.
ICU care is
often necessary
because of dysautonomia.
They could develop
arrhythmias,
bulbar dysfunction,
severe and rapidly
worsening weakness,
evolving respiratory
distress, which can be
seen in their inability
to count to 15 or
more during a single
breath, and there can
be a rapid decline in
respiratory function
that needs to be watched,
this can occur in
over 30% within 24
hours. So when a patient
like this comes into
the emergency room,
they're often watched
closely and very often
put into the ICU
because they can become
very sick very, very
quickly, even if they're
looking fine when they
initially present.
And the treatment
of Guillain-Barre
includes supportive
care, which
is the corner
sort of treatment.
They are also
treated with IVIG.
Plasma exchange are
equally efficacious.
Either one should be
started as soon as the
diagnosis is confirmed.
In this condition,
steroids have not been
found to be effective.
CIDP is chronic
inflammatory demyelinating,
polyradiculoneuropathy.
There is symmetric
proximal and distal
weakness and sensory
loss that develops
over approximately
two months in a
progressive stepwise
relapsing course.
They're reduced or absent
reflexes, and
usually there is no
antecedent illness.
There is less common
dysautonomia and
respiratory failure, which
is in contrast to the
acute or AIDP, and
there can be a postural
tremor present.
the treatment
for CIDP could be
one of the following,
either IVIG,
corticosteroids, or
plasma exchange, and
50 to 70 percent of
patients will respond
to at least one of
these therapies.
The neuromuscular
junction,
as you can see pictured
here, is the next area,
and this is a 23-year
-old healthy woman
who presents with
several weeks of
intermittent diplopia,
difficulty with
climbing stairs, and
it becomes worse at
the end of the day.
On exam, there's
difficulty sustaining
upgaze, mild lid
ptosis, and bilateral
hip flexor weakness.
The differential
diagnosis of
neuromuscular
junction disorders
include
myasthenia gravis,
Lambert-Eaton
myasthenia syndrome,
botulism, or immune
checkpoint inhibitor
-related myasthenia
gravis, which is a
newer condition
seen with these new
medications, the immune
checkpoint inhibitor.
And this is an image
of ptosis or drooping
of the islet, and
that's seen on
the patient's right
eye, you can see the
drooping, which can be
seen with myasthenia
gravis, especially
at the end of
the day, or if
someone's getting tired.
So autoimmune
myasthenia gravis causes
fatigable ocular limb
and bulbar weakness
to different
degrees. It's more
common in younger women
and older men, and
the antibodies
are seen against
acetylcholine receptor
antibodies or musk
antibodies in the
majority of patients.
Musk antibody
positive patients
can more often
present with
difficulty swallowing
or chewing.
It's a highly
treatable condition
with immunomodulation,
and often
a thymectomy may
be warranted.
Lambert-Eaton myasthenic
syndrome is more
rare. It's an
autoimmune disease that
affects the presynaptic
neuromuscular
transmission. There
are antibodies against
voltage-gated calcium
channels. Half of
the patients that
have this also have an
underlying small cell
lung cancer. There
is proximal muscle
weakness, hyporeflexia,
and or areflexia
with dysautonomia.
Weakness and
reflexes will
briefly improve
after exercise.
The treatment for this
is 3,4-diaminopyridine,
and they need to be
seen by oncology for
an underlying cancer
if that's the cause.
botulism is a paralytic
illness that's
caused by botulinum
neurotoxins and it's
produced by a strain of
clostridium botulinum
it inhibits acetylcholine
release at the
neuromuscular junction
this causes an
acute descending
flaccid paralysis so it
starts from the top
and works its way down.
A patient can be
affected by either
ingesting the toxin
foodborne. There could
be wound colonization,
either intestinal
colonization that
can be seen in an
adult or an infant,
or with cosmetic or
aerosolized, obviously
not intentionally.
The symptoms that
occur may include
blurred vision, slurred
speech, descending,
paralysis, and
respiratory failure.
And getting into the
muscle, these are
the myopathies.
A 70-year-old man
presents with a tear
history of progressive
lower limb weakness.
He describes
that his knees will
give out. There is
weakness of deep
finger flexors and left
quadriceps in an
asymmetric pattern.
So, inclusion body
myositis is the most
common myopathy or
muscle disease in
adults. It affects
males twice as often
as females. There
is knee extensor
weakness that's most
prominent with loss of
ambulation over 10
years, and over time,
there's loss of
swallowing and
respiratory involvement
as a cause of death.
The symptoms that
can be seen in a
myopathy include
exercise intolerance,
muscle atrophy,
weakness, muscle cramps,
muscle contractures,
muscle hypertrophy
depending on the
type the patient
has, myoglobinuria,
there's pain in
muscles at rest or
with exertion
depending on the type.
And the differential
includes different
inherited myopathies
including dystrophinopathies,
inflammatory
myopathies such as
inclusion body or
polymyositis and acquired
myopathies which
can be induced by
medications like statins
immune checkpoint
inhibitors and also
thyroid ophthalmopathy
is acquired as well
and on and to the
right is an image of
a patient with a young
person, most likely
with an inherited
myopathy, causing
this calf hypertrophy.
There are multiple
muscular dystrophies. To
the right is an image,
as there used to be
different
fundraising events.
There is myotonic
dystrophy, Duchenne
muscular dystrophy,
Becker muscular dystrophy,
fascio-scapular,
humeral, and Emory
-Dreyfus muscular
dystrophy, and
limb girdle
muscular dystrophy.
And so in summary,
hopefully you will have
some idea about how
to localize lesions
based on clinical
presentation, generate a
differential based
on the localization,
and try to not miss
a treatable diagnosis
knowing what the
appropriate treatment is.
Thank you very much
for your attention.